hi guys and basically what I'm going to
do this episode why am I even why am i
skipping my intro and what I'm not
really saying anything so you know I
really say something in the beginning of
a video I don't know why do people we
can do that why do people have intros
what's the thing what why does PewDiePie
say that whole thing that he says that
I'm not going to do because I don't want
to make things awkward now I am only
five seconds in the video and I'm
already ranting about random things but
yeah I am just doing some small things
in this video no more skyscrapers
because basically I built a three Scott
actually for know I built three in one
episode and that for a small American
town which isn't even supposed to that
many skyscrapers in the first place
that's kind of ridiculous I guess I
wasn't a skyscraper crazed or something
like that though you could argue you
could argue that I am never not in a
skyscraper craze but that's besides the
point I am just going to just do some
small things that I need to do in this
episode like making that little crossing
over there because you do need to get
out to the other side somehow now I also
need to pick up some custom scenery sets
for these for those little things on the
road when you have like a railroad
crossing because I don't really have all
of the objects for that only of the
things that Bodines gives most house but
um at that point that was finished
because it's just a small thing and I
felt like I need some more support
buildings on the Main Street not
necessarily a Main Street but you could
call it the Main Street without one
street that leads up to the downtown
area you get what I mean and I felt like
okay so I've kind of got this and
classic style that's kind of probably a
bit too European for American city
cities but then again it kind of it does
have that sense of power and wealth and
all that and Americans lava okay no but
yeah it's a somewhat common thing and I
just like the way that it looks so I
figured well I might as well go for it
so I just decided that I would make
another building like this to kind of
mimic that style that I had going on
with the other buildings except this
time a little bit more small and a
little bit later and maybe I could even
put a shop in it or something like that
and the moment that I built this I was
reminded of a SimCity building so I was
like hmm I'm going to add the same kind
of roof that that building
and so try Main Street didn't really
look like it but it looked pretty cool
so I went with it anyway so that was
pretty cool and really this is just one
of those support buildings and I don't
know I really like building these things
for some reason it just you just have
this general area and it looks so
unfinished and so very rollercoaster
tycoon is not really realistic in any
way but then as soon as you start adding
buildings like this just to fill the
gaps and finish everything off it just
works in a very nice way to kind of
create that real city atmosphere so
that's pretty cool and those almonds
have bits a little bit too well bright
red I figured but just decided to go
with it anyway because really what other
choice do I have no other awnings really
fit that stuff and at that point it's
just finishing the back of the building
I kind of want to finish all of the
backs simply because this is going to be
a somewhat realistic city so I don't
want to have weird things going on where
you wouldn't necessarily look around I
kind of want to be able to walk around
in the city how even with three of the
cameras something like that and actually
feel like you're in a realistic city but
I kind of also don't want to spend too
much time on the backsides of buildings
because obviously you barely see those
things and obviously I want to move on
to the fun stuff too like planters once
again flowers everywhere because flowers
are awesome and I love them so really
this also kind of shows how effective
plants are at while making something
look good in a sense where you get those
ugly concrete buildings it's so nice to
just get some nice flowers and trees and
stuff like that to actually get some
nature in there get that nice things
that all the left parties want and then
your city looks more green and nice so
that's really cool and at that point I
was like okay so I've kind of free to
finish that area and then it was look
around time for me and I figured okay I
also want to and a building over here
and then I was like yeah that doesn't
really work and then I was like I'm
going to add some buildings over there
and that did kind of work in a sense the
general idea that I had with this was to
add like some small facades that you
would have liked the Chicago facades
that too many people are funneled in the
roller-coaster kanthri community I see
so many people doing those things so
much that I am kind of I kind of don't
want to do them simply because they're
somewhat overdone and I'm also afraid
that I won't be very good at it compared
to all of the people who practice so
much with it and stuff like that
but even though they do look good I kind
of wanted to go for a Dutch facade for
this building which does make sense
historically somewhat since I guess you
kind of do have some Dutch influences in
some cities somewhere but not too much
but I just felt like might as well go
for it and the only problem that I
really had with this was the fact that I
needed to get a full tile placement
obviously because that's easy to work
with but just one tile would be very
narrow that won't work but two tiles is
kind of already too white so the
buildings already look a bit too low
since Dutch facades are usually much
higher and more narrow in their
appearance so that doesn't really work
out that well so I'm not too happy about
these buildings I just decided to finish
them off at windows and everything that
I really need everywhere to just kind of
save them but then I felt like okay I
want to move on as quick as possible but
then I looked at the backside and I was
like how I still haven't even added the
back side of that building yet so just
have to do that anyway because when well
yeah big sides are important you can't
forget about those things especially for
that building where it's pretty high and
you kind of look at it from many angles
so you kind of don't want that to look
weird and this building has four floors
it's not even that much really the only
problem that I have with silver City as
of now and that's probably going to stay
um yeah it's going to stay there is the
fact that it's somewhat small when it
comes to scale and the normal houses and
normal buildings are somewhat well
scaled obviously they're not too big not
too small really but the skyscrapers and
stuff like that
even though they are so much higher and
so much more well I wouldn't want to
call it aesthetic but so much more
pleasing is also weird word to use I
don't know
just more unique in their appearance
that like they look like they've
actually kind of been designed and
actually coat cost a whole lot of money
but the thing is that the highest
skyscraper only has 16 floors and that's
really really small I mean even in the
town where I'm living was like 50,000
less than 50,000 people there are
buildings with more than 20 floors and
this is this is just for such as town to
have such a skyline yet the skyline
being such low buildings it's kind of
weird in a sense though I do like the
way that it looks when it comes to scale
it's maybe not the best thing but really
if I would have added skyscrapers that
were the size in the height of let's say
the Empire State Building because we're
mainstream and cliche it would have been
terrible the Empire State Building would
have just dwarfed every other building
in the city so that wouldn't work either
so really it's just it's just the
problem of wanting to create a city in
rollercoaster cone 3 with skyscrapers
and a skyline but the city shouldn't be
too big because obviously you can't
create a city the size of New York in
Juanico ii 3 but anyway I'm rambling on
I've built an entire building almost in
the time that I've been talking about
that but really this isn't all that
special so I guess I haven't really
missed out in anything this is just a
building where I felt like ok I kind of
want to have a office ish kind of
building yet it also has to have that
sort of house look I don't know it
shouldn't be too out of place within
like the that Street which is going to
have all kinds of American houses and
American houses and why do I do that but
I felt like something simple and it's
also funny that from that building from
like when you're looking at the facade
of that building you can see the skyline
looming up in the distance and that's
actually pretty cool and the funny thing
is also that the walls that I used and
that one little glass kind of prism
shaped that I have on top of the roof it
kind of looks like kind of reflects the
style that these skyscrapers have in the
downtown area so that's really cool and
in the middle of this I decided to put a
park because once again I'm a fan of
putting nature everywhere and flowers
really I've been talking about so Sim
City as well since that since that was
one of
the main well yeah that was kind of
where I got my idea from in the first
place watching SimCity 2013 thinking
that's terrible I can do better and well
I'm not necessarily that but I did get
inspired by SimCity but even when I play
some city I just plays parks and trees
everywhere even though that's not the
most efficient way to play it I just
like to do it like that so I like that
kind of works for a roller coaster
grande 3 as well and at that point I was
like ok this this parking lot doesn't
have enough trees yet so I decided to go
on a hunt for places that didn't have
any trees or benches or any of that
ornamental stuff that I so loved and
decided to place all that stuff
everywhere because everyone needs some
trees and flowers and some some some
benches in their lives honestly they're
amazing and at that point why am I even
oh that's actually pretty cool nice
lights hmm I'm a genius sometimes yeah
definitely
well those lights are integrate Y and
replace them with those lights that's a
lot better
good job silver Rick you did well anyway
those lights are really good but yeah
that's it for this episode just a small
episode doing some small things and
thank you so much for watching guys and
I'll see you on the next episode so bye